I I have a kind of a question because
you see so much in the media like uh you
know the classic psychologists like kind
of a couch like this somebody's laying
back and you know telling their story
but why why just the act of verbalizing
it does that help so much now if we're
in a cycle there is a false cycle of
just
um just talking talk therapy that's not
a cycle that you want to get into gotcha
all they want you to do is talk and talk
and talk and talk you can write that
stuff out right it'll do the same effect
but it's much more you want someone to
help you to make the connection in your
life you know the learning aspect is
invaluable yeah
LED live
with mental health issues on the rise
today we're going to talk about
understanding your mental health and we
have a special guest Dr Dana Phillis
Saint thank you for coming on the show
with us so excited to be here this is
awesome we've been trying to connect for
a while and thank you for your patience
but um this is a topic that we are
seeing more and more of and we've done a
couple of pieces on this but I'm really
excited to hear some of the tools and
and from what you I understand we're
going to get into is if you can kind of
understand how how or what triggers this
okay you can be able to deal with it
right that's right that's right so
understanding the whole cycle actually
gave us a whole picture I think
sometimes we tackle this topic of mental
health in isolated cases right
depression or here's anxiety or here's
fear or here's you know trauma but what
is the whole picture right if it's about
the brain right so it's got to start
from somewhere where did it start from
and how uh where can we go with that to
actually help people to understand how
their mind actually is working now give
us a little bit of your background you
um you work in um like a clinical
setting that's right so we have a center
downtown Somerville Georgia called Mind
care and we also have contracts that we
do with the county so we go to schools
we do some assessments there we do some
presentations
in various locations so we also have
written some curriculums for mental
health for various youth programs and so
forth so we're really diving into
helping people to understand that the
Lord Acts actually has a method of
dealing with mental health I love it
that you're calling it mind care because
you think about people take care of
their body people will take care of all
kinds of things that's right but you
don't really hear about people taking
care of your mind as much so I'm excited
to dive into this topic good deal good
deal so understand the mental health
cycle so this is how we can see the
whole picture there's actually a cycle
to understanding this there was a story
that reminds me of of how I actually
went into this field and and why it is
that we do what we do but there was a a
lady she came into our office this was
my last client of the day I was tired
I'm not gonna lie but she came in with a
12 year old daughter actually was a son
and uh she you know started you know she
didn't even smile or anything look she
was like look help me this child right
here I have had it he's stealing lying
and cursing and and he's just now got
kicked out of school I don't know what
to do I heard that you're a psychologist
change him I'm like change him hold on I
wish I had that kind of power right but
wow let's see what's going on and so the
kid was sitting there he didn't say a
thing and usually when we deal with
children and we like the parents to be
there because obviously they learn
they're seeing something something is
happening to them to get them to that
point and so
um this was one of those cases I I
questioned if I should have had the
parent in there just how negative she
was about her her son but it brings a
different topic for for us is do we can
we really change people you know can we
really get to the mind and say you know
you're no longer depressed right is that
what we do is that what we're about when
we hear the word psychology do we do you
know some kind of magic to change
people's mind and the answer is actually
no we don't right there's no factors no
you know reset button but what we can do
is give people the right tools and the
right education and lead them to the
right source that can actually change a
person and so
um you know one of the uh Power really
cool quote presentation things that I've
read in along the years was a book
called Mind character and personality
have you heard of those words okay and
and page eight it says great wisdom is
needing and dealing with diseases caused
through the mind and then she continues
to say understanding the mind and human
nature AIDS and the work of Salvation
and lastly in order to lead souls to
Jesus there must be a knowledge of human
nature in a study of human mind so I
think what it is is we need to spend a
lot more time understanding the human
mind so that we can actually get the
whole picture across on how to help
people right because there's all kinds
of influences in our world and and you
know a lot of these things are are
influencing your mind and and it seems
like you know there's not a lot of focus
on the mechanics of why is this
happening and you know it's like we put
all this evil media out into the world
but then nobody questions like what is
this doing to your brain you know that's
right you know a lot of our information
sometimes we get from Modern psychology
how it started right we had individuals
trying to answer questions like these
you know who am I what is life what is
God what is a thought where is the mind
what is the soul it is the soul the self
what is memory and how do you know this
is how psychology got started people
were trying to understand these
questions and so they came up with
various theories right and a lot of us
have bought into a lot of these theories
you hear Freudian Theory you heard of
Maslow Theory trying to understand this
concept but what the problem is they
fell short of understanding what the
Creator have created design our minds to
be and of course they don't address the
the topic of sin they don't address the
how salvation can be brought about and
it definitely does not understand the
concept of the gospel and so they missed
out a lot of that basic and fundament
fundamental uh information that we need
to understand the mind and so
um people are struggling to know who
they are as a result I used to live in
Japan I was telling you guys that
earlier and one of the things I know if
I can play that from here I might have
to play from here but one of the things
that was really popular there is Anime
oh yeah cosplay all of you guys already
about Cosplay but there there are people
who go into the world of their you know
anime characters Fantasy character where
they would actually go and even get
surgery done to look like the character
that they sold adore and love and like
the Comic-Con contest that's the one day
Halloween that's what Halloween is not
the one day Halloween things every day
this is who I am trying to figure out
who I am in this world
um and again they don't know who they
are and the risk of not knowing who you
are is very dangerous yeah I had a young
lady that came to my office I used to
work for the military I've been in Japan
and uh one of the thing is whenever they
had a suicidal thought they would have
to talk to someone to find out what the
risk level of their suicide is and then
see if they needed to you know go to the
hospital to come up with a plan for them
and this young lady she was about 15
years old and she was escorted to the
office and she sat down I was asking all
these questions and uh she didn't want
to really answer anything but finally
she goes what's the point I said what do
you mean she says well I get good grades
you know I go to school I'll eventually
have a career I'll get married probably
and have a house and then I die so if
that's the point I might as well just
get to the end and say whoa yeah that's
a different mindset I mean when you
don't understand that there is actually
a purpose for your existence right you
know there's something Beyond there's
something Beyond there's no hope if it's
like this is it and you have a bad
existence here that's sad that's right
that's right yeah so the choice is
always said to us you know in the Bible
choose life choose life that's what
Deuteronomy tells us to choose life just
some statistics for you guys and why
this is so important in uh 2019 the CDC
did a research and seen what is the
mindset of High School is right now when
it comes to depression and anxiety and
those kinds of things they found out
that 36 almost 37 percent of every high
school student was saying that they were
depressed now now is this something that
we're just recognizing
um or we have more data or more tools or
is it actually like these numbers are
getting astronomically increasing and
this is 2019 so this is before the
pandemic so now even with the pandemic
it's actually gotten even higher did
they do this annually they typically do
it when they do the the surveys you know
that they go go around and do and find
out um what's going on in the schools so
it's not yearly unfortunately so usually
around every four or three years
whenever they feel like there's a need
to do it they're doing but the Le the
last one they did was 2019. I'm sure
we're gonna unpack a little bit of this
because I have this question mark of why
what's what's the cause of all this
um yeah I know I know media we've
studied media of quite extensively in
the past few years and when we were
doing a documentary about social media
one of the things that kind of popped
out was that there was a sort of link
that the more that they played with it
the more depression they actually would
experience and even so so I've seen
interviews of there's kind of like a
like a tech psychologist in the in the
area of Silicon Valley his name is gero
and he's he's kind of a real crazy
looking guy and he said don't go there
yeah well he was literally like saying
like companies know this data this is
not something that they're like unaware
they know that we're putting this kind
of Technology out and it's causing this
kind of a result that's right and I can
give you a little bit of information
even now just to let you know that
temptation is really strong the
Temptation out there to to know to get
to you know be part of something that's
hype and new
um is very strong an addiction that
comes with it is also you know that what
this that's what keeps us in for a long
time unfortunately so even with those uh
students they're seeing that almost 19
of them were saying that they seriously
are considered suicide man almost 19.
and then uh almost 16 have actually had
a plan design
for them to commit suicide some almost
nine percent have attempted
um 2.5
have been injured as a result of it now
they're not telling you the number of
students that's actually been you know
have committed suicide and so forth but
it's good to know where we at and so
that we can actually help those that are
still here right and so you wonder what
is it like in the church then right if
we're talking about you know high school
and this is like high school Nationwide
this is Christian non-Christian and so
forth how about in the church there was
a survey that was done in this in the
churches to see what is their idea about
mental health and and where we at with
that in the churches uh some 47 said
that they do not feel supported right
now when it comes to their own mental
health in the church wow another 35 said
that they believe that prayer and Bible
will help them okay now for some you
might say well that's not a large number
for someone's like well at least 35
right yeah however you say you see it
it's still you know if you see this at a
church setting
um and then some four percent said that
um out of all the individuals that they
know that have committed suicide only
four percent said that they were aware
that they had some issues that that
individual has some issues and then
um some 32 percent said that they know
someone in the church their family
members that have committed suicide
another
um 65 said I wish we would talk more
about this suicidal thing or this mental
health thing and it's not being
discussed as it should be in a church
and then overall they asked all the
churches only 27 said that they actually
have a plan to help people in the church
and then um you know 49 of pastors
actually admitted this is not a topic
that they talk about in the church oh
yeah oh yeah I don't know if I've ever
heard a sermon on it there you go now
there you go so 49 said they have never
in our community we just had a a
um a young child uh he was you know
teenage major age and they ended it
ended his life and and it was a hard
thing for a lot of this community around
us here and you know
it I'm sure it's a difficult thing to
navigate do you want to talk about it
you know I'm sure if you have a family
you don't want to talk about it I mean
what do you do in that kind of a
situation that's right is it best to to
kind of you know begin conversation I
mean that's true that's a hard thing
absolutely talk about it because the
thing is someone is already thinking
about it right right and so if we can
talk about at least they have now a
chance to unravel some of the things
that they're feeling inside and don't
feel so much in isolation in their minds
right right and then this is interesting
cool too that or
um percentage 23 of pastors themselves
admit that they themselves are
struggling with mental health wow right
so this is why you know when when you're
talking about why to lead a person to
Jesus is so important to understand the
human nature not only that but also the
study of the human mind so we need to do
a lot more of studying and let's study
this mind that God has given us and I
remember when I was studying just that
the thought came to me that everything
comes in Cycles right if you think about
there's a water cycle right and then we
study that in in science class there's
there's uh the the the
um the Eco cycle and then there is the
plant life cycle everything comes in
cycle how about learning even learning
has a cycle right if you ever read The
Book of Proverbs that's a powerful book
a wonderful book with instructions and
so forth but you also constantly see
four words constantly popping up the
words of instruction wisdom
understanding knowledge right all those
and first you might think it's the same
thing but it's actually not what we're
finding what I found through my study of
Proverbs was instruction is you know
when you're listening to something if
you're watching anything you're being
instructed on something wisdom then it
tells us this is something I want to
take in this is this is Meaningful I
think it's wise for me to take this
instruction in right understanding is is
when you're able to not only take this
in but able to see and show that you
understand you apply it so there's an
application format that comes with that
uh the information that you got that you
gathered and knowledge now is your
ability to take this information and
then go out and share it right so it's
not the same thing so while you see you
know there's wisdom not everybody gain
wisdom we can get in your your parents
probably were trying to instruct you
right but you didn't want to take
everything in yeah right so you weren't
wise and to follow the plans that your
parents taught you or understanding you
never demonstrate that you understood
anything right or if you're in school
you're not really applying anything that
you learned so you didn't show that you
understood it and of course a lot of us
are not going out and teaching or
sharing the things that we know so
that's knowledge so we don't have that
knowledge to share so that's the cycle
of learning I love it that God did
designed in witnessing the opportunity
to share with other people because it's
I think that is one of the things that
really helps it sink into us that's
exactly it yeah and I I mean I've tried
to do this with my kids like just
teaching them how to cook you know
sometimes my kids will be like Dad make
me this maybe that and I was like well
there's the pan and I'll stand over you
and help you learn how to do it because
it's much more powerful if he learns how
to do it and then all of a sudden it's
like he's he'll he'll enjoy that skill
the rest of his life that's right if I
constantly do it for him he will never
teach somebody something are there any
groups where like for example the high
school students I'm backing up a little
bit where the uh it's maybe a sub
demographic that depression is higher
like for example you know we a lot of
all the kids we notice that the ones
from a single family home or maybe
there's a particular ethnic group or a
financial demographic or something like
that or maybe something unexpected like
you know it was like uh 80 of them were
like honor roll students or something
right right are there any sub
demographics where it's higher where you
see spikes good question so you know I
don't know the answer to that I haven't
seen any literature that shows
particular groups has hired or than the
other but what we're seeing overall if
they're they're all increasing it
doesn't matter you know one thing that I
have seen and have no notice is that in
poor country kids tend to be more happy
that I have noticed this is true I mean
it is really fascinating my family and I
we took a
um a mission trip to Africa this this
last year and you know you play with
these little kids who have nothing yeah
I mean absolutely nothing these these uh
we went to an orphanage and the girls
had a little metal box at the end of
their metal bed and all the contents of
everything they owned was in this little
box and they looked like they were
totally fine I think one of the main
reason I believe is that they're less
tempted there's less Temptation they
don't have to they don't have the means
to go and be tempted with name it
alcohol or you know whatever the video
games or with temptation I'm sure then
comes guilt that's right
yes that's exactly it there's some uh
you know a good example of of the these
words being in Proverbs give
instructions to a wise man and he will
be wiser teach a just man and he will
increase in learning the fear of the
Lord At the beginning of wisdom in the
knowledge of the Holy is understanding
so that's a really good promise to see
that these three or four words are
actually not the same thing and take
some time to study for yourself and
you'll see so this is this is what I
have seen that there is actually a cycle
to mental health so there's and I'm
going to break it down a little bit more
but there's experiences that people have
with these experiences I found that a
lot of them are tempted based on what
they're thinking their words their
action and their habits that follow if
it is negative then they're more likely
to be tempted in something if it's
positive they're less likely to fall
into that same Temptation and then with
that it changes the whole person and
then you get character right
um so let's let's break it down a little
bit more so the first is understand what
is mental illness what is mental illness
we hear about it all the time but what
exactly is it uh so it's it's defined
according to the American Psychological
Association as health conditions that
involve changes in one's thinking and
one's emotion their behavior so their
changes that are taking place so that
Mom was actually correct that there are
changes that that was taking place in
her son's life by the way some more
information about this kid he was um
left in a home by his biological mom
um that was using drugs so this was
actually his stepmom that bought him in
and he was left there for over 12 days
on his own when he was one oh okay so
was there trauma there before there was
something happening and no one has
discussed because who did he talk to no
one has ever discussed these things with
him but he feels or they believe that
now that he has a great home that's not
his issue that has nothing to do with
his issues right so there are always
some kind of event that takes place that
we need to unravel at times
um and is that what's occurring right
now in his life or does he need to talk
about something that no one is listening
or hearing him talk about so all of that
to say is there's also that it's
associated with distress or problem
functioning in the social and work and
family environment another thing the
fact that we need to understand is the
word character
what is character character is how you
know your habits your motives your
thoughts and everything that makes you
who you are so your emotions yeah you
know everything about you creates your
character the only thing you're taking
to Heaven is your character he's your
character it's your character So based
on the definition that I told you
earlier about mental illness I'm going
to change the the definition just
slightly and put the word character
there okay so mental illness is actually
a health condition that involves changes
in our character interesting right
because it's all about it
context it does it really truly does and
why is character this whole thing so
important just like you mentioned right
we're told that every Act of life
however unimportant has is influence in
forming okay everything that you do
influence the character I've always
heard of it as a character broken down
into thoughts and feelings right it's
your thoughts and feelings and and I
mean music is made up of like literally
characters thoughts and feelings right
the feelings is the is the emotional
piece or the music aspect and then the
thoughts are the words that are attached
with that and I mean movies do that they
mess with your feelings but they're a
bunch of words that they're putting
together so there's a lot of things in
life that we have that influence this
aspect of our being a little bit yeah
yeah absolutely so we're told also that
you know good character is very precious
is the most precious thing that you can
think of if you think about it this way
when you go to an interview the first
thing they want you to do is give them
some references I need some references I
need some recommendation letters from
you so we can hear what someone else is
saying about you even if you're going to
buy a car or a house or a loan they all
said I need references we need to know
something about you that we can trust
right so that's all about your character
people are checking to see who is this
person what character do you have do you
have a solid character kind of like what
they're doing in China right you know
character social
numbers not really
the Harvest of life we're told is
character it is that that determine our
destiny both were you know this life and
the life to come character does not come
by chance it does not come by chance to
a great extent everyone is the architect
of his own character and I love that
that's interesting because if you are
the one that can create or design the
character that you have I mean there's
something that you need to know of how
to go about doing it right so other
things to keep in mind uh that defective
character is not something that that
just happens it does not just happen and
what I think is neat too is is God has
intended the creation to be able to heal
right I mean he's built the system it it
can be broken in many times like this
young boy that that you know one years
old I can't even imagine like right the
trauma that he went through I'm sure is
is programmed that poor child into a a
world of you know problems but right is
it reversible good question
um I believe that God can change
anything in anyone amen I really do I do
I do I think however though there are
things that happen to us that we can use
that he can use to impact
a greater number of people so your story
you can use your story to turn it to
some kind of testimony that others might
want to be attracted to God right so he
allowed things for various reasons right
one-year-old you know he had nothing to
do with anything at that age
um and so you know how does he how
should his mind uh interpret the event
and that's what we're going to learn too
is how how should we interpret events
because this thing called life ain't
easy you know what I'm saying just like
that it's not easy so we want to make
sure that we don't portray that a
Christian Life is easy it's not it is
not easy I remember I was having a
conversation with my husband a while
back you know a lot of time we put a lot
of praise and you know we want to hear
testimonies about people who've left the
church and then they've come back and
it's like powerful it is powerful but
you know what else is powerful when a
young person can stay in the church yeah
amen that's powerful amen because the
Temptations and the struggles are real
I'm actually always impressed by that
speaking with young people
um sometimes you know we'll get into a
conversation about drinking or drugs or
something like this and every once in a
while when I have some young child come
by and say I'm never engaged in that I'm
always like how did you not do that I
mean that's impressive to me I think the
other way is way more easier yeah it's
like the you know most common story
that's a unique story that somebody
doesn't engage in that activity it is
absolutely and I think sometimes we need
to understand just you know trying to
stay in that narrow path you know need
to be celebrated in a sense because we
need to know how you're able to do that
when everybody else is is falling and
you have not fell how did you resist all
of the Temptation that came your way
because they are going to come they came
I'm sure you know so character is said
um is formed by hard Stern battle with
the self with self right so getting back
to this this idea of the cycle
um you know I remember reading uh books
like Christ's object lesson and again my
character and personality and Ministry
of healing and trying to decide and
understand what is character and we saw
it there in those books as well
character makeup is makeup from your
your action the habits the thoughts and
the feelings those things that make up
your character and then there's
something that happens called
experiences of life when these things
happen it is then up to us every
individual should I have a thought a
word or action or habit that will become
negative or should I take that same
experience and have a word an action or
habits and so forth that is positive and
depends on the track that you take will
determine where your mindset go okay so
I got a Biblical example for you for
that Joseph yep I mean we're talking
this is a guy that that exactly sold by
by his family members kicked down lied
and he remained to say I'm not going to
let this change my character that's
right I'm going to remain integrity and
and and look at God honored that and
made him the second in command in the
entire world absolutely and because of
that you know when a person goes towards
the positive mindset even regardless of
the experience and I.E said trauma even
regardless of the trauma that a person
experienced they are more hopeful they
have more courage their faith increases
and then so they're more likely to have
sympathy towards others and then uh you
know based on those courts as well their
health increases and that prolongs life
now when the other side as well you were
going to say something too well health
increasing
um you mean when you have positive
thoughts it physically has a result on
us so uh my my mom used to have this
like funny little phrase that when we
would start these negative thoughts or
something she would say stop that
stinking thinking and and she would she
would tell us like you know those
thoughts can actually cause us to you
know be sick or something so right
that's right there's research that's
actually backing that up big time Big
Time what what's the difference though
or what's the line with
actually avoiding your problem and then
being positive about it that's a very
good question so I don't think you
you're called to avoid your problem your
talk you're told that God is the
solution to the problem right and so
it's identifying and going through the
problem is actually a healing process
within itself and it's a growth process
so a lot of times people go you know
around and so the mind's like what do
you want me to do with this one you know
I can't avoid it it's still there this
happened to me for real right and so
we're not talking about this we're not
talking about going around it and that
causes more heartaches than anything
it's about going through the process God
says let's take me through the fire with
you right and so it's not avoiding and
start thinking about positive I'm not
going to think about this it's dealing
with it how do you want me to deal with
it sometimes positive things come out of
a trauma right people write wonderful
books or movies or you know uh help
someone just help someone else a program
as a result of what they've gone through
or even on a slower a smaller scale they
know how to parent much better because
their parents were horrible parents
right and so they're things that God
wants us to to learn and it's always
about learning it's always been about
learning mental health you know to to
really understand trauma and everything
else in between is what is the lesson
because there is a lesson yeah there is
a lesson um not not I deserve it it's
not that and that's a lot of time that's
the problem they start taking it in so
personal like why this has happened to
me and you know I am ugly or I'm
worthless and all those you know
self-talk of of what it is to be me
that's the negative thing that we want
to get out of because all those are lies
every last one of those things are lies
not no experience create those things
you accepted those lies and so those
lies are just that if they're lies what
is the truth you are invaluable that's
right there's no number
you exactly exactly um I I have a kind
of a question because you see so much in
the media like uh you know the classic
psychologists like kind of a couch like
this somebody laying back and you know
telling their story
but why why just the act of verbalizing
it does that help so much now if we're
in a cycle there is a false cycle of
just uh um just talking talk therapy
that's not a cycle that you want to get
into gotcha okay
um when you when you share and it's okay
to share and I'm perfectly fine with
people sharing it's not just come okay
next week did you thought what would you
thinking about this talk therapy is not
what God wants us to be about it's about
the lesson it's about the learning
process and so if you're going to a
counselor and all they have you do and I
have seen it because I've gone to
counselors myself right all they want
you to do is to talk and talk and talk
and talk you can write that stuff out
right it'll do the same effect but it's
much more you want us someone to help
you to make the connection in your life
you know the learning aspect is
invaluable yeah right and so how can you
take that information and create
something grander how what is it what
does God want you to see and understand
about Sin about him about the gospel
message that can do phenomenal in your
life as a result regardless of the
experiences that you've had so it gets
bigger than just you know let's talk
about it let's talk about it if that's
what you're going for beware so no no
rant sessions every time please don't
I'll be a listener I'll charge half
and again I'm not saying it's a bad
thing to go and share and I have heard
people say oh don't go sharing your
problems with people there are people
who are holding things in their hearts
yeah is to share with someone you know
and God will present to you this is the
person that you should share with right
and it's okay to do it there's
absolutely nothing wrong with that now
if you believe that this person is your
god or like this Mom
um you know change her you know change
him you know that that's a whole
different concept you know we're we're
not God we are not God and we should
never take the place of God so we can
tell people and tell share with them
pray that's where you share all that
detail and as much as you want and
whatever else in between and God will
connect you to people that will help you
either make connection
um see things in a different way and
that's that's a healing process and
sometimes you're stuck in just one way
of thinking that you can't see any way
out or any way else than the way that
you've been thinking or even behaving in
such a way like if you start getting
into addictions those kinds of things
please seek out help right absolutely
yeah yeah the question
no I'm just mulling something over but
I'll bring it out maybe in a little bit
yeah yeah I I do just want to um
so do you think there is a place
in the church for because okay so
there's this mindset that you can't have
um like if you're struggling with mental
health and you don't believe in Jesus
enough
um what do you think about that because
if we do believe that Jesus does have
ultimate power and in the Bible we just
see people being completely transformed
right what does it say about the person
who is continuing to struggle or who has
to let's say they go through depression
um they have to like put in a lot of
effort they have to make sure that they
you know have like make that space or
energy in their schedule to spend time
with God and then to make sure they
exercise but it's a burden the whole way
through that's right how do you good
question good question so one other
thing too we had to understand is our
mind is housed in our brain right and so
the brain is an organ just like your
heart and just like your lungs and
everything else and sometimes there's a
default in that right and so with that
said it's not a shameful thing if the
pain is in there and so there's ways of
going about it just like there's a way
of going about it if you have a heart
problem if you have a you know a lung
problem it may not necessarily be
medication all those kinds of things
because they're always natural ways of
going about things as well right and so
whatever path that the Lord is taking
you to to get that healing seek him out
to see what what do you want me to do
should I share should I not share
sometimes it's not necessary to go and
share I tell you that all the time you
know I tell people that all the time
just because something comes to your
mind doesn't mean automatically I need
to see I need to go see a psychology I
need to go see a counselor and it's kind
of weird coming from a psychologist
saying that right but it's not necessary
to always go seek out you know when God
says I have the solution for this
particular one or this is the situation
and God can show you what that situation
is so it's it's really being connected
with God in such a way that he can show
you this is what I want you to do with
this and it might be go talk to someone
because you can't hear him clearly and
that happens that absolutely happened
when you when your soul sometimes
depressed your mind cannot see anything
else than what is seen right and
somebody might might be able to lead you
in a different path that you don't even
think yeah oh wow okay now I can see
just a little bit clearer just listening
to you talk it's like I can't imagine
not having the god element as a part of
the help solution like I know that
there's a lot of people who don't
believe in God and that there's all
these ways that you can help solve this
but it's like you just cut straight to
the guy who who made the hardware that's
the bottom line we're creative beings we
really are and that's that's when that's
when you really understand the mind you
really truly can see that there are
things that you have absolutely no
control over unless you turn it over to
him yeah
I think it's comforting to know that
you know even if you're not even if it's
not safe or or maybe not wise to share
with somebody else you can always share
with God absolutely you know you can
always go to God absolutely pour your
heart out
you know and tell him anything so
there's always you know there's always
at least one person you can share with
absolutely every time absolutely I was
just sitting here thinking about
um you know if you're coming from a
Christian world view
it's kind of fascinating to think that
all of God's thoughts are right
and the reason we're kind of in this
mess in the first place
yes because we can choose our own
thoughts and because there was a
rebellion in heaven it started with
incorrect thinking like choosing the
wrong thoughts and that's why the battle
remains right there the battle of the
mind we're told right that's the whole
thing it's where there's a battle in our
mind and it is that same battle that
started from the very beginning God
wants our mind and so does the enemy he
really really does what your mind is it
Corinthians it talks about bringing
every thought into captivity of Christ
that's right I mean that's that's that's
just like the ultimate picture of like
is every one of my thoughts subject to
to yeah God's thinking yeah yeah
um I wanted to ask too because I know
this is also something controversial in
the church is if someone takes
medication yeah for their health is that
something that shows a lack of faith
that's a very good question I think God
reached with deal with us where we are
at
and sometimes I will say that person
probably need that if this is where
they're at and God wants to reach them
there and then there are other people he
you know he they they're at the level or
or so forth where they say you know this
is not what I want God can reach them
there too right I think we we need to
lead that judgmental part out and once
we do that God can do his work so much
better than we can right
um there's a lot of controversy of
course the medication because of the
side effects but that's for every
medication right so let's not tackle one
and not deal with the others right right
so if you're talking medication let's
not talk about just one kind of
medication let's talk about all the
medications are so you're not taking any
medications at all right even skin care
and we openly take it yeah God reach us
where we're at and we gotta remember
that and so where that person is may not
be where you're at and that's okay that
is absolutely okay
so good questions yeah good questions I
love it so what are these experiences
you know one of the things that's really
um hyped right now is the word trauma
you guys hear trauma trauma trauma
trauma everywhere right trauma and then
there's a definition for trauma it's an
emotional response it's to terrible
events like and they give the examples
of accident abuse neglect a rape
whatever else in between but one of the
things I can tell you that trauma could
be anything
it really could be anything for anybody
what might be traumatic for you might
not be traumatic for someone else right
bullying right now is like very
traumatic for a lot of kids I don't know
any kid that wasn't bullied to be honest
but that's a whole different topic for
whole different you know time but you
know that could be traumatic for them
but it wasn't traumatic for you why is
that right so let's let's let's uh not
judge someone's trauma let's identify
okay they were traumatized let's accept
the fact that they were traumatized if
we start going there and that's why I
like dealing with uh trauma because it
looks different for for everyone and it
leaves room for all of us to be
accepting of whatever the problems that
they have and so that they can present
what their traumas are and still
understand and see that
um that their trauma is what's actually
impacting them okay do you think that
um
how it affects people also stems from
their upbringing because I can imagine
let's say you have someone who
experience emotional neglect or whatever
when they were when they were younger in
the home and so when they go out into
the world and you hear things like oh
you're stupid or you're dumb or or
anything you're ugly and you believe it
versus someone who grew up in a more
secured home and then they have someone
bullying them and they think well that's
not who I am I don't care what you
exactly and go about their life do you
think that stems absolutely those first
five years absolutely remember we talked
about the the cycle of learning it
applies even for negatives yeah right so
the instructions that we were given at
any age we could take that and say
that's that's for me right and so we can
start living our life in such a way that
we apply the very negative thing that
someone had told us about ourselves and
then that cycle still continues because
now you're treating your own children
the same way so it's that same cycle
it's a cycle of learning whether it be
positive or negative you can still apply
where you know it just continues that
same negative cycle unfortunately right
on the positive side
um you know especially raising children
um you know giving them the love and
nurture from a parent perspective
especially a father to us to a daughter
right right she grows up with a oh I am
valued and I am loved absolutely whereas
if she didn't have that there might be
that hole you know so it looks for it
that's right she does love her at the
same time so there's that aspect of
wisdom you know I have seen parents um
raise the the very best to raise their
children
you know we gave them everything that
they needed
um the wisdom the Bible you know
everything homeschool if you want to
call that the ultimate you know
education
at the same time to those kids still
fall away why is that right well but
they also have a choice because it is a
choice factor that even still that even
if you were raised in a horrible home
that you can still have the choice and
say no that's not what I want so I think
that sometimes people forget there's a
learning aspect and there's that wisdom
do is this something that I want I think
a lot of times people don't take time to
analyze and study you know we're told
that self of assessment is a good thing
assess yourself you know think about the
things that you think what are you
thinking what is your mind set on so
that you can actually go above or change
you know those kinds of factors as well
so would you say you know trauma just
like just like people have physical pain
and you cannot experience somebody
else's physical pain traumas like that
mental
um injury that you experience pain from
and and so in the same way you can't
you can't compare you know like you
don't know what somebody else is going
through like I have one child you would
think every time something happens to
him it is he's dying you know it's just
like his pain is so great at least to
him it's so great it's unbearable that's
right that nobody can understand him you
know and if you just think about it it's
so over the top every time yeah he's
he's a very sensitive person whereas I
have other children it's like yeah you
know it's not that big a deal and
they're not as sensitive you know so if
they get you know fall down and hit
their knee it's like you know
he's like hey you're bleeding oh yeah
it is it's very personal but what I
really like is um I don't know if you
ever study Isaiah 53 right God they can
always relate to God because he says
like I've experienced all of it right
and so you point that person to the
right store they can start seeing okay
yeah you can't relate to me at all and
that's what the gospel message comes in
so helpful and and handy to anyone right
you may not understand it I may not
understand because I did not go through
that trauma that you're seeing that
you've defined
but someone has someone has so that you
can again start connecting them to that
Source I think that's interesting
because God does have different ways
that he describes how he can relate to
us and I know like for me the biggest
thing is friend yeah and for other
people it could be father for some
people it could be like you know people
say like you're the son of a king or
you're the daughter of a king for me
I've never been royalty I am not in a
culture that deals like when people tell
me that I'm like okay I don't care about
that even one you know so it's like but
for someone who may be like I don't know
in India and they deal with past systems
that is super like relatable and that's
something that's like wow I have this
much value so I love that God does have
these different ways that he can connect
to us yeah you know often time again
because of those negative thoughts the
words and action that are negative the
anxiety and so forth comes about in the
mind so I'm becoming depressed and so we
have with what's called mild depression
you've heard of mild depression it's
just a mild depression where you know
the person is feeling irritable very
angry hopelessness comes in and feeling
of guilt the stress self-loathing a lot
of time comes in the activities that
they used to like they start you know
not liking it anymore so you can kind of
see their behaviors or their character
start changing doesn't everybody
experience this at some point that is
that is possibly true what would you say
would be the percentage of people that
that deal with or have at least some
level of it has been said and there's
research that shows that at some point
of your life ninety percent of the
people will experience the pressure it
has to be yeah so so you know that that
is the truth that is the truth however
it can go toward towards moderate
depression or even severe depression you
know or very and the problem though is
if it's not addressed if you just kind
of stay in that level and then or you
get deeper into your depression which
has happened it can actually uh [__]
a person where they're not even going to
work anymore they're not waking up in
the morning anymore so then you're
talking about a serious a case of
depression where their mind their soul
engulfed in their minds about everything
in their lives that is so negative that
you know
Suicidal Thoughts start coming in and
then it becomes really problematic we're
told that when it comes to Suicide the
World Health Organization estimated that
in some 800 000 people commit suicide
every year oh wow in the world
so 800. so let me ask you this because
you know we may have
um a lot of young people that watch our
Channel or something or parents that
have young children
um do you need to check in with your
children absolutely everything I mean
life I mean like I've never had a
conversation with my child like hey you
know have you ever considered suicide
like I think building that trust is
important and showing interest in their
life it is it is and and you know
honestly the more there are times and
and I'm gonna say that for some parents
that I actually know who's their their
children have committed suicide that
that is one of the hardest thing that a
parent has to deal with and it is not
the parents fault at all I want to make
sure that they understand that every
single day the enemy is throwing
Temptations and and things as your
children every single day he's he's his
aim is to take the kids out your
children out because there are powerful
weapon in this battle right and so
that's his aim and so it is not the
parents fault but often time the
children's mind can be so caught up in
whatever it is for for a long time or
even a short time that the parents
didn't even get a chance to catch it
right and then so of course
unfortunately you know the these young
lives were cut too short right so
whatever we can do now you know even
those individuals they have a powerful
tool now that they can even use to go
and help other parents beware look I did
not know so that's another way of
looking at it now you know you can use
that trauma to go about helping as many
people as possible because the enemy
does not want you to do that yeah so
yeah I I think that this should be
talked about in schools in churches we
talked about with young people like I
just don't think we put enough emphasis
on understanding this and there's such a
stigma against it if somebody's
depressed or you know struggling or
whatever and then it's just kind of like
okay well you know
and it's not contagious at all yeah I
think that's that's a bad way to deal
with it it's actually the second leading
cause of death between the ages of of
kids 15 to 29. wow second leading cause
okay maybe I'll get canceled for saying
this but
or asking but I I know that social media
is very influential
and what we watch does impact us and we
all want this sense of belonging and
community
do you think because I I feel like I've
seen this where
depression is romanticized and so you
could have people who are not really
depressed but they just kind of carry on
that depressed aesthetic because it's
just what's cool it's what's in it's
what makes you the cool person you
create the cool art or the cool music
and it just gives you this whole
different yeah it gives you an edge and
I feel like I'm seeing that all
throughout the culture yeah is is that
it is a thing it is definitely a thing
actually
um I remember there was a school that I
was working and I won't tell the school
for a while almost half of the fifth
grade class you know was saying
something where they needed to go and
get analyzed to see if it's you know a
real risk or is this you know they just
want to get out of the classroom you
know so while that may be the case I
think there's that lack of understanding
who you are yeah so who are you right
and so why what what is the motive
behind the things that you're doing
um that that needs to be analyzed more
than anything or share so that kids can
understand that their uniqueness makes
them cool yeah it's not just falling
into the category that makes them cool
it's not just having the latest or
saying the things that's the hip or
whatever else that makes them fit in
that makes them you know who they are
right so and again understanding who you
are is important understanding that you
your your your life mission is also
important so all of those factors when
you're talking to your children teach
them that you know uh I remember
um reading Desire of Ages and how from a
young age Jesus knew why because his
parents would tell him constantly you
know John the Baptist his parents their
you know his parents were telling the
same thing as parents you know let your
children know that you were were born
for greatness you were born if God and
by the way if you have not asked God
what is the purpose for your children
ask God he will tell you just like he
told all the other mothers and all the
other parents he will tell you the
purpose for your children yeah right and
so that way you can start training them
from very young you know I really have
this hint that God really wants you to
go into this now they may avoid it they
may not want to that's okay that's okay
but as long as you're training them um
it's interesting growing up my mom my
parents I just say they used to give my
my older sister things like you know
stethoscope for my sister you know all
those medical stuff now she's a nurse
and you know like it's interesting how
that kind of go along the influence
always pays off eventually if anything
they have they will have the interest
sometimes we allow children this is I
might get caught up on saying this one
but we allow the children to kind of
figure out their own lives
you know what I'm saying and it's not
necessarily a bad thing but what if you
can kind of give them the steps after
you know asking God and being aware that
that would be really good at and you
start motivating or teaching them in
that path what if you know or you'll see
kids like they really love dinosaurs so
the parents go and start buying
everything dinosaur dinosaur it's like
you know yeah that's cool but yeah
you know could there be something else
yeah
technology I think I think that
um yeah there should be a balance
between because of how I've there are
some parents who just shoved down their
own dreams down your throat or all they
care about is I want you to make money
in life I don't want you to struggle but
then there's also like I guess how I've
always viewed kids is like it's a gift
and God has given you this person to
take care of who is going to evolve into
something that he's created and I think
that comes with a lot of responsibility
and it's like I don't think you should
force or tell your child who they should
be but rather do take in like be aware
of what they are
um what their interests are let them try
new things because I mean I was
interested in ballet tapping Jazz when I
was young but I'm not doing that now I
didn't you know have a dream to go to
Juilliard and do it but it was fun to do
I think I learned a lot of lessons from
that but of course yeah I think giving
children the space is important
space and also as God right what it is
that your children were created for that
again he will tell you you ask him
sincerely you know and so you can be
doing that prayer with your children
right right yeah
um and also
um I wanted to
um add to when you talked about how
important is to know yourself yeah um
yeah because I think especially in this
age of horoscopes like I have a friend
who follows that just religiously and
we're born in the same month and so we'd
be considered the same zodiac sign but
then like they'd say things like oh yeah
like I'm this this and this and I'm like
no I'm not like this does not fit me
whatsoever and I just see how easy it is
to like just I need to fit into this
yeah and then you take on these
characters I see it on the same time
with Instagram there's all these
psychologists on there now who are
telling you oh you have if you're
depressed you experience all these
symptoms and then I see people adapting
to those symptoms that they didn't have
before they read the post so I'm just
like anybody could forget something
couldn't forget that they put something
in the fridge like you know it's just
little things like that and I'm like
what are we doing at this point do we
even know how to live our own lives and
things for ourselves that's right are we
just trusting other people to tell us
who we are we need to be very careful
yeah the mind is powerful it is
extremely powerful and we do react off
of suggestions I mean television's
gotten really good at that suggesting
constant things to you and and molding
and shaping cultural mindsets you know
yeah yeah and the more the most popular
thing I'm getting right now is hey I
think my child needs counseling and like
for a reason I don't know just make sure
that he's okay I'm like really because
everybody's going counseling now so you
know it's it's interesting it's very
interesting but you're right we need to
be very aware that your children has an
individuality yeah you know and God is
has created him that way
um and be mindful of all the traps that
would take them away from that
individuality to create them into
something else yeah right
I wonder if to
um
if there do you know of anything that
will help parents deal with this because
I I counseling is a lot of money and I
feel like sometimes they do it because
maybe parents just don't have some
parents don't have the emotional
availability or the resources so is
there anything that will help parents
could be able to help their child or to
definitely share about that but one of
the things that I have been you know
working on with some friends and
colleagues of mine is curriculum for
parents you know just take it's a book
you know just go through the curriculum
with them and talk about you know the
Temptation talk about the various things
that have impacted them the trauma their
traumas whatever they that trauma might
be it might be someone step on their toe
they don't know how to react they start
you know tantruming whatever that trauma
might be for that kid you know you deal
with that in a way that you are the one
teaching them learning in lessons that
children can learn now from their
parents are invaluable they will
remember those lessons yeah they will
remember those lessons so
um so going towards that you know the
the media is full of cases now there was
a young lady recently that had committed
suicide and the parents blamed the
social media and they actually won but
they did they did but all the it was
actually um meta and Pinterest they
apologized wow wow Pinterest
pictures
well that's the thing with algorithms
now if you look up one thing it'll cover
your feed with that so I can imagine if
you're saying quote like I remember
because I was in this space at one point
in time where when I was depressed I
literally only got things on my face I
mean you literally it was and it was it
would be things that just completely
reinforce how you feel and it even got
to the point that there was this this
GIF GIF whatever you want to say it was
like this little moving picture of a
train coming towards you and it was
angled at the track and it said close
your eyes when it gets close enough and
those were things that I was exposed to
there was no positivity so I can see why
they won they should have won so so
you're bringing up an interesting point
here like um why is it that you
gravitate towards like depressing you
know like in the 80s Depeche Mode all
those like depressive musics that people
would always listen to which seems like
it would just put you more in a state of
depression yeah like what is what is
some things that you you probably want
to avoid anything that's going to even
right you know I'm just going to go
straight to this point because I think
this is this is where we're at this is
extremely important that we're talking
about this
um and I'm if we have time we can go
back into
um where where are we where are we
uh so
whenever situations happen in life okay
you can call it I.E trauma experiences
that that's traumatic for one person
um the minute we engage into negative
thoughts the negative actions the
negative whatever that's changing your
character negatively then you give the
enemy ground to say Hab at me right and
so what he does the Temptation that he
has played on you to engage in that
negative thought now says to him I'm
going to give you I'm going to give you
my spirit because you're negative right
now
the negative Spirit didn't invite I
really believe that the unkindness the
the everything that we're reading
Galatians 5 right
um the the even appetite the increase of
appetite that's a spirit that's a whole
different Spirit he said this is my
spirit the spirit of unforgiveness
right I truly believe that I'm not
saying that you know for those who don't
believe in the Bible you know but this
is this is what I truly believe that the
spirit comes in those negative Spirits
because you've allowed it in and those
are the cause of all the the depression
and the level of anxiety that people are
having
so what if
I'm thinking of the of the young boy
who's one year one years old what if it
had nothing to do with you or let's say
someone who was raped what if you that
wasn't your fault it's absolutely not
their fault absolutely not their fault
the experience has nothing to do with it
and it's kind of weird that I'm saying
that it's what happened after the
experience your thought then becomes
negative your thought then becomes you
know your action becomes negative the
minute you said I'm just gonna I just I
hate this thing I hate life uh whatever
the negative thoughts that you're having
and more times than not the thought
leads to your emotions or emotions leads
to your actions right those things the
the the the cycle of those things in
your life is what invites that Spirit
but let's say like what if though that
experience didn't happen
I I feel like the experience is
connected because if that experience
didn't happen then maybe that person
wouldn't be in that situation I would
tell you that there are people who never
experience anything negative like that
and their their mind because of their
thoughts and negative whatever else that
they have still goes into that mindset
of depression I know people who they're
like I don't even know I'm depressed
there's not nothing ever happened to me
yeah I'm just sitting here trying to I
I'm thinking about the person who goes
through something traumatic yeah and
the natural because we live in a world
of sin that's right is the natural
reaction is to have a negative reaction
like exactly if you get raped your first
mindset isn't going to be like I'm so
glad that happened that's right that's
right you know you you are you are
because of sin and because of humanity
you're kind of predisposed to have a
negative reaction to something that's
right that's right you know you know the
researchers um came up and he said this
is that kind of kind of what you're
saying he says what if Depression was
not a disease but a normal response to
abnormal Life Experiences you know he's
like what if that's the normal way of
going about it and he's absolutely right
and so what we had to do we have to be
abnormal interesting we really have to
be abnormal in this world because
naturally when someone step on my toe I
want to step on it back there's back
that's the natural reaction that we have
so the whole idea of you know turn the
other cheat that that's not no normal
stuff that's the abnormal way going back
to Joseph if your sibling sold you I
mean seriously sold you into human
trafficking I would be Petty when they
came and asked for the grain you know
what I'm saying
could you yeah could you
reacted
oh now you want it exactly
but that would just be me and myself I
would be so caught up in the moment but
he was petty we do need he was happy
when he came against Benjamin
no he was testing yeah
because he has something against that
little boy I think there's probably
something that just just to clarify
where you're going with this and that is
you're you're coming on the side of the
response right to the negative action
right not necessarily the feeling that's
invoked by the harm that's inflicted
because that's why I'm clarifying
because yeah I right the response and
the emotions because sometimes people
have bitterness inside and we have sure
yeah but I'm I'm just I'm I go back to
that like that rape case right right and
I can't see an instance where anybody
walks away from that and they're like
I'm so glad that happened
that's what I'm trying to clarify
absolutely
no no no no no you're not justified
you know that was horrible absolutely
horrible but you're talking about the
response to the events that is correct
afterwards not necessarily your
emotional reaction to that was about
happy all of us so you're saying if a
person is willingness you're saying if a
person's willing to after going through
that they deal with it and then are
seeking help because they want to
proceed
and move on right okay right right and
it's not necessarily move on because
sometimes people like they they can they
can create a life work as a result of it
they can see their purpose as a result
of it right and so it then give them a
chance to share the gospel message in a
way that is unbelievable I'll give you
an example now this is like one of those
like far-fetched and I don't then see
myself ever you know God forbid anything
like that whichever happened to anybody
but it happened to this lady where you
know her worst nightmare happened she
had a 16 year old that went to some kind
of party and then she got the call you
know
um your son was murdered you know it's
like what you know she was in her 30s
long story short you know four many many
years later
um he the the guy who did the shooting
he was being let out earlier I think you
see 17 years or something like that
because of good behavior she went to the
prison
and said I want him to live with me wow
real life yeah what
he was like you know obviously this is
what those were her words the
forgiveness was for me it's not for him
and all and then she goes in instead
talks about how
um you know he obviously did not have
the right upbringing he did not have the
love he didn't understand connection of
human that he would do something of that
nature I want to be the one to show him
that of course this man's life is now
changed and everything else in between
but for her to do something like this is
beyond the norm
is beyond the norm and a lot of us you
know as Christians we're called to go
beyond the norm
and that's the difference and I said
this before the Christian life is not an
easy one right yeah I I've mentioned it
on this show before I don't know if you
guys have been in the show but um there
was a lady who went through the
Holocaust she was part of the mangleth
twins that was experimented on her twin
sister was really really heavily
experimented on yeah and she forgave
them she literally after the war went by
and sought out the doctors in Germany
and said I forgive you you you you you
you don't understand why you did what
you did but I forgive you and she lived
a normal life after that I think
everybody experienced trauma on that
yeah and it was through the act of
forgiveness that helped her heal that's
right this traumatic experience I mean I
can't even imagine why you would not
just come out completely crazy from an
experience like that seriously and she
lived a normal life so there's something
about the way that you respond after
that terrible thing that happens that
that's what I've that's exactly that's
what you're doing that's exactly it
that's exactly it
um and I have I mean the same similar
you're going to say something no I was
just thinking about how that's that's
really God's response it is
like I forgive you yep it is the god in
you it's only the goddess
well I mean yeah it's not not just not
just God in us doing that but just God's
response to humanity yeah yeah like he's
demonstrating the way forward like this
is how you function yeah this is the
only way you can function yeah the only
way you can function I think it's crazy
too that when someone wrongs you and you
do forgive them and express kindness
towards them that also ministers to them
because that changes the person who's
forgiven as well but when you don't it's
just I don't know it's just crazy and it
continues the cycle yes it does it does
and it forgiveness is a hard thing to do
it is awesome hard thing but yeah it is
it is necessary but you feel so much
better when you do yeah you feel so much
better
um so you know again it's not the trauma
that we're really talking about like if
it's good or bad trauma is bad the
person that's experiencing is bad okay
so that's the that's negative right but
it's the response to us to it that that
really makes the difference in our
mental health yeah period our response
to it makes a whole huge difference but
it's healthy to be sad it's very healthy
if you don't that might be questionable
right right I just want to clarify that
because I know I like just keeping in
mind our audience members who may just
like have trouble connecting with that
and think oh well am I not being
positive enough but just it's so
important to go through all those
emotions it is okay it is okay to go
through these emotions yeah it's part of
the process it is definitely the process
and and some people might go through it
much quicker than you yeah you know so
it's not a level of let's compare and
we're always trying to to figure out how
long does a person greet you and how
long should that's not what it's about
it's a journey that God has taken
somebody on and again he's so
individualized he has calculated
everything about everyone's life so
while we're looking at this and thinking
what's my scenario does it apply to me
it's how is he relating to you and this
uh factor and one of the things that's
important to God too wants to put his
spirit in us right and so the way that
he does that when our thoughts and you
know our emotions and everything are in
line or we're seeking out his thoughts
and emotion through the process process
he says let me give you my spirit a
spirit of love that's when that whole
forgiveness concept just kind of makes
so much sense yeah and then as a result
and science is always also sawing it you
know courage and hope and
um uh faith and sympathy all those
starts increasing even in your health
even in your health we're told that
healing takes place when gratitude is
there compassion is there and love is
there there's that restoring power that
happens in your body you've heard of
people with cancer and their body and
all this are thinking positively and
they start seeing things differently and
then you know tumors are doing certain
things it's like whoa what happened
right so the the body and the mind is
really connected it's we're just one
being yeah we really are just one being
yeah right have you ever read um any of
that those books that talk about their
as connection to various different
diseases to various different like
responses to like trauma and things like
or if somebody's like experiencing a lot
of anger and always angry in their life
that they like tend to have cancer of
the bowels and I've heard that I mean I
I haven't you know dove into the
research to see how true it is based on
the clients that I have but I have seen
I have heard of that those studies and
it might be this might be a lot of
validity to that might be a lot of it we
do know that the body the mind you know
the Mind Body follows the mind it really
truly does you know even your hormones
you know based on how you're thinking
your stress hormones does things and
it's just like whoa you know now it's
you know Run Stop digestion and you know
all sorts of the kind of thing that
impacts how your body is supposed to do
and work as well so yeah yeah so it
really it boils down to this um John 10
verse 10 the thief come not but to still
to kill and to destroy and that's what
he wants to do it but God wants to give
us Abundant Life right and so we're
talking about resources and so forth and
so one of the things that we've been
working on is given creating resources
for people to really understand the
working of this mind how does the mind
really work and quick guide we have a
book called The quick mind mental health
guide our latest one is called mental
health curriculum for youth we spend
some time on that and it's chapter by
chapter with activities with stories
with questions to ask the youth you can
do it in format of individual if you're
homeschooling you're one kid or you know
in the church setting and so forth or
even in the schools if you have time you
know if there's a counselor there's a
teacher there the same things that see
things that's happening in a classroom
you can you know get some really good
information on how to address the mental
health where can they get these go to
mindcare.us also we have a curriculum
based online instructions that they want
assistance on that we can also provide
that in
mentalhealthuniversity.net so that's us
doing some of the demonstrations or
teaching with their youth or or they can
do it themselves or they can go there to
get some training on how to go about
doing it themselves so we're trying to
make all these things available so that
no one has any excuses for not
addressing mental health in your school
in your home in your churches because
we're told that not enough of this is
being talked about and as a result the
very battle that we're all under you
know where the battle of the mind we're
not winning it a lot of people are not
winning so we want
um you know to win this battle with
Christ we want to truly win this battle
with Christ in using the resources that
God has put upon our heart to share so
it sounds like you need to start a
YouTube channel
do you have a YouTube channel that's a
good question we do we do we do need to
utilize as much more F and P which is my
husband F in fmn M what is it f and D
ude it's my last name it's my last name
is f and D philistate so f for France
and D for Dana philistate is our uh
YouTube page but we do need to utilize
it a little bit much more yeah you have
some great information so we'll put a
link in the description below where we
uh you can get a hold of some of these
materials or you want to look into it
more but
um Dr Dana thank you so much for coming
by and blessing us with this uh very
intriguing conversation uh do you speak
at churches or schools do we do we're
actually about to go to Pennsylvania
next weekend so we're looking for that
for this I think it's called Blue
Mountain Blue Mountain Academy very cool
very cool so yeah yeah well um I think
it's a very important topic and if you
are involved in your church or your
local school and you want to address
some of these topics please communicate
with Dana here and uh I think these are
very important topics that that we need
to start sharing light on and we felt
passionate about doing a show in in this
vein so please like it subscribe share
this with anybody that you guys think
would get a benefit out of this thank
you for supporting our channel for your
prayers uh we we continue to put out
content because of the generosity of you
guys so thank you for those of you that
have donated to our ministry and uh
thank you for checking it out that's
right I just want to close with this
thought based on everything that you've
shared since it's all about the mind of
thought Jeremiah 29 11 which says for I
know the thoughts that I think toward
you says the Lord thoughts of peace and
not of evil to give you a future and a
hope
[Music]
foreign
to show kindness to the world
every day is an opportunity to do
someone know you're thinking of them
every day is an opportunity to give
without expecting anything in return
[Music]
every day is an opportunity to notice
someone in need and to go out of your
way to help them
foreign
to do one small thing
to show someone you care
to make the world a better place
hi you might not know me because I work
mostly behind the scenes
but my name's Michael and I'm the
director of little life Studios 3D
Department
right now we're experimenting with new
technology where we're trying to blame
reality with the virtual worlds it's
more efficient and offer us the
opportunity to make higher quality
Productions with better visuals by using
the online engine software it gives us
the possibility to create realistic
virtual environments for sets in a short
amount of time
we are working with what we have because
we do have Financial limits that's why
we're working toward getting an LED wall
in the future because it will allow us
to use extended reality this simply
means that we don't need green screen
anymore
it will save us tremendous time in the
post-compositing process
we will also have realistic accurate
lighting that comes from Led wall which
matches the subject and the set in real
time
actors are able to see the set rather
than having to imagine the scenes within
the confines of the green screen
so that's what we'll be up to here at
little eye status
we're so thankful for the ways that God
has blessed us
and we're so excited for what he has for
us in the future
[Music]